hey everyone is lazy and this is btw on
Vsauce what's on the plate for this week
how about some video game cliches
whether it's save points health meters
three lives there's certain things that
have shown up through generation after
generation of video game what if we
could take those cliches and put them
into real-life the first one is all
about health if I had the chance to
capture this concept I would not only
save the medical world but I think I
would help out a lot of different people
like those people on jackass be about it
you can either eat something like a
mushroom or you take a potion my example
comes from Castlevania where you eat a
piece of chicken to get full health
[Music]
or you just eat a bunch of double downs
that might always help the next cliche
is a concept that's using tons of games
I could use so many examples but I'm
gonna use the example from n64 Goldeneye
in which you have tons of items on you
at all times and yet you look perfectly
normal
no one would ever think that James Bond
is carrying a grenade launcher rocket
launcher or machine gun because he looks
perfectly normal is tuxedo right
[Music]
have you ever noticed a lot of different
games especially in RPGs that you have
those menus that pop up that have
different phrases that decide your
destiny or where you're going in the
game do you ever think that those might
help you really like I mean a good
example would be on a date perhaps tits
or gtfo or romantic walk on the beach
[Music]
you don't turn the key of destiny only
you have the power to control it the
power to choose a path I want to start
the car to greatness
I wanna go have the strength to wield
this power I wanna [ __ ] gun always
watch let's face it our world revolves
around money
so in games it's a common thing that you
can get money for beating stuff up so I
thought what if you could kill someone
in real life without consequences
and get money
[Music]
well that's all I have for you this week
I hope you enjoyed what you saw if I
forgot a video game cliche that you'd
really like to see go ahead and put it
in the comment section below until next
time I'm Lacey and bTW there aren't any
extra lifes IRL
you
[Music]